et voilà est ce que cette émission va
être aussi relevé que ça ne s'est pas
tous les ingrédients sont là alors on va
parler un petit peu mon cas la radio a
les yeux on a ouvert un petit salon de
châtier dans le xviiie oui
châtié tout c'est ce que c'est non c'est
comme barbier mais pour les chattes non
à la radio elle a alors la radio du
salon parle du salon oh ça va falloir
d'entre eux que moi je passais
désolidariser non bien évidemment la
radio non sur une survente 2 mais nous
subissons un autre 18h et 19h c'est
l'autoroute de la fortune
on est très bons joueurs ils vont des
candidats qui me téléphonent depuis leur
voiture est évidemment très fier content
donc quand on a fini lario on file au
salon on enchaîne juste après 19h sur
comédie la grosse émission en direct
avec toute l'équipe de la grosse
émission vous connaissez que vous aimez
bien sûr will assuré bien sûr et voilà
j'ai on va regarder ce qu'on fait c'est
qu'un pas